bismillah al hamdulillah assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh may the peace
mercy and blessings of Almighty Allah
the Creator has earth be upon you happy
Ramadan my law bless your Ramadan the
Dean show going on 11 years 500 episodes
and we're calling on you we do our
campaign once a year asking everybody to
contribute you know it takes money to go
ahead and pay these bills and to help us
to continue to serve the community to
serve humanity by getting the truth out
by clearing these misconceptions
millions are spent to get people away
from Islam we're asking you to
contribute very little to help share and
bring people to this beautiful way of
life Islam now what are you going to do
with that how much are you going to put
in how much are you going to contribute
to help us grow this channel to continue
the work it's something that's incumbent
on all of us we've taken up the call
we're doing our small part may allah so
allah accept it from us and from you as
you contribute there's a link below and
we'll see you next time keep us in your
duas subscribe if you haven't already to
get this newest show delivered to you
every Friday we release it helps support
the Dawa helps support are spreading the
message of peace and purpose to the
world until next time we'll see you less
salamo alaikum peace be with you